I have always found that if I leave a
language for a while and particularly if
I study another language then when I
come back to the first language I'm
often better than I was I've called this
sort of benign neglect and I'm not sure
whether the language continues to
gestate in your brain or whether it's
because you tried this other language
and struggled with that for a while then
you come back to the first one and the
first one seems easier but I have always
found that that there is no loss in
leaving a language for a while other
than the fact that you're not spending
that time with the language so you will
perhaps progress more slowly by not
having spent the time with the language
however you won't slip very much